wer sich fragt wann und wo Polen zum
ersten Mal spürt dass sich was ändern
könnte kommt vielleicht auf 12:7 Uhr um
das Wahllokal 591 in Warschau hier kommt
der vielfach verhöhnte und vielfach
verleumdete Kandidat der Opposition aber
Donald Tusk sieht bereits wie ein Sieger
aus der Chef der Bürgerplattform weiß er
kann nicht die meisten Stimmen bekommen
aber die meisten Sitze wenn er es
schafft eine Koalition mit dem
linksbünden und dem konservativen
dritten Weg zu bilden was dafür noch
fehlt um 12:15 Uhr ist eine hohe
Wahlbeteiligung 14 Uhr Berlin das ist
die Schlange vor dem Wahllokal für die
in der deutschen Hauptstadt lebenden
Polen Berlin meldet Rekord dann meldet
Warschau Rekord und bresslau und Oppeln
und Stettin dann ist die Wahlbeteiligung
so hoch wie noch nie im Freien Polen und
dann ist es 21 Uhr
wir haben es geschafft
wirklich ich habe keinen Zweifel dass
dieser Tag in die Geschichte Polens als
heller Tag eingehen wird an dem eine
neue Epoche beginnt die Wiedergeburt
unserer
Republik zwar gehört der größte Balken
im polnischen Fernsehen auch diesmal
wieder zur rechtsnationalen
Regierungspartei peace aber als deren
Parteivorsitzender vor seine Anhänger
tritt muss
äumen es gibt eine
Frage die Frage ist ob es möglich sein
wird unseren Erfolg in eine weitere
Amtszeit unserer Regierung
umzuwandeln Kinski hatte im Wahlkampf
ausgeschlossen eine Koalition mit der
rechtsextremen Partei konfederatiia zu
schließen jetzt muss er entweder
Abgeordnete zum Überlaufen bewegen oder
einen anderen Weg vielleicht einen
juristischen finden um an der Macht zu
bleiben den ganzen wahkampf über hatte
die Pace und das von ihr in einen
parteisender verwandelte öffentlich
rechtliche Fernsehen versucht die
Kandidaten der tuskpartei als
Befehlsempfänger Deutschlands
darzustellen nach einem Sieg will Tusk
den Einfluss zurückdrehen und die
Verantwortlichen
bestrafen ich bin der glücklichste Mann
der
Welt dann ist es
2:12 Uhr und die Opposition tanzt falls
jemand fragt wann genau der Wechsel in
Polen
begann